today on the matt wells show as the
student debt crisis continues to spiral
out of control the wall street journal
publishes an article asking us to feel
sympathy for ivy league grad
students who are drowning in six-figure
debt after discovering that their
master's
master's degrees aren't leading to
lucrative jobs who would have thought
for some reason i struggle to feel any
sympathy
for these people we'll talk about that
also five headlines including former
media
media darling michael avenatti gets his
prison sentence
rand paul looks to revoke the federal
mass mandate on airplanes
and we'll discuss the latest alleged
racism controversy over at espn
and our daily cancellation will cancel
scarlett johansson for complaining in a
recent interview
that she is underappreciated and also
underpaid she makes like 50 million
dollars
a year though talk about all that and
more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know everybody wants privacy when
they go online and i i think
most people think well you just put your
browser in incognito mode
and that's all you need to do and you
get all the privacy that way but
uh it doesn't always mean what you think
you know we all take little risks every
day when we go online whether we think
about it or not
we think our connection probably won't
be interrupted by hackers our data
probably won't be used against us
but using the internet without
expressvpn that just doesn't make it's
like driving a car without insurance
it's you're taking a risk
that you simply don't need to take why
take that risk every time you connect to
an
unencrypted network cafes hotels
airports any hacker on the same network
can gain access to your personal data
whether it's your passwords your
financial data your financial details
whatever it is
that's the kind of risk you're taking it
doesn't take much technical knowledge
either to do it
just some cheap hardware a smart 12 year
old could do it i couldn't do it
but i'm not as smart as a smart 12 year
old and your data is valuable hackers
can make up to a thousand dollars per
person selling personal info on the dark
web so what do you do about this you get
expressvpn
you can secure your online data today by
visiting expressvpn.com
walsh that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn dot com
slash walsh and you get an extra three
months free at expressvpn.comwalsh
there are a lot of villains in the story
of the student debt crisis it takes
more than one bad guy to get us to a
point where there is now at last count
1.7 trillion dollars in total
outstanding student loan debt 1.7
trillion dollars by the way
is more money than currently exists in
circulation in the united states
now most people aren't paying off their
student debt in cash obviously but
this is just a way of gaining
perspective there is more student debt
than there is physical currency in the
entire country
collectively how did we get here who are
the villains exactly well
the universities would have to be at the
top of the list they're the ones
charging exorbitant tuition fees for an
education that is
rarely worth the cost and even when it
is worth the cost
there is still no reason why it should
cost that much
much also we should blame in equal terms
the government the banks
the public school system for pushing
kids into the university system to begin
with
many parents too must take their share
of the blame for pushing their own kids
into this
and what about the employers who fuel
this madness by requiring degrees for
from
entry-level applicants who will be
performing jobs that do not actually
necessitate
having a degree we talk about all the
jobs that need
degrees and most of the time the need is
artificial there's no reason
there's no real reason why a person
without a degree can't do the job it's
just that the the employers have
put that requirement there artificially
the vast majority of jobs are learned by
doing
so most jobs are learned in other words
on the job
there's no reason why that expensive
piece of paper should be necessary and
yet employers
often require it out of pure laziness
because it's an easy way to whittle down
the applicant pool without having to put
in much effort so
all of these parties deserve blame then
what about the students themselves
who take out these loans personally i
would much prefer to blame
the powerful and corrupt institutions i
already listed
and the adults who should know better
instead of kids just out of high school
who are too dumb and naive to understand
what they're getting themselves into
i mean everybody is stupid at 18 i
certainly was
and that's a good reason why 18 year
olds shouldn't be granted six-figure
loans in the first place
it's also a good reason why they
shouldn't have the right to vote by the
way
so i'm sympathetic to the idea that many
of the people saddled with this debt
are victims they were exploited
i don't know what else you can say about
about saddling kids fresh out of high
school with this kind of crippling debt
does that mean that i think the taxpayer
should have to pick up the tab and foot
the bill for student
debt forgiveness absolutely not
you cannot undo the exploitation of one
group
through the exploitation of another
if you want to grant some kind of
student debt forgiveness for some people
by seizing the endowments from these
universities
then maybe we can talk but the only
thing more unfair and immoral than
handing out
massive loans to ignorant 18 year olds
is forcing taxpayers who didn't take out
the loans to pay them back
and the college graduates who demand
that such a system be put in place
for their sake immediately lose all
sympathy from me
you have all this debt i'm sympathetic
but the moment you point to me and say
and say to the government no
force him to pay it back no more
sympathy
you're no longer a victim the moment you
try to right the wrong done to you by
committing a wrong against someone else
someone steals your car i feel bad for
you you steal
my car in exchange and now you're just a
damn
thief like the guy who took yours that's
how that works
but there are some supposed victims of
the student debt crisis who ought to
engender no sympathy at all
from anyone in the first place the wall
street journal just published a piece
yesterday which
highlights this group the headline
alongside a photograph of a man in his
thirties looking sad and dejected
reads quote financially hobbled for life
the elite masters degrees that don't pay
off
columbia and other top universities push
master's programs that fail to generate
enough income for graduates to keep up
with the six-figure federal loans
this is an article all about the
pathetic saps who took out massive loans
to pay for graduate school ivy league
graduate school and now are
as the headline suggests financially
hobbled for life
now something to keep in mind as i read
some of this to you and and this is very
important
the average age of a grad student is 33
and that means that a great many of the
people currently in grad school are my
age or older
so these are not kids these are grown
adults
so here's what the article says quote
recent film program graduates of
columbia university who took out federal
student loans had a median debt of 181
000 yet two years after earning the
master's degrees
half of the borrowers were making less
than 30 000
a year i'm sorry it's not funny but it
kind of is uh 30 000
a year that's minimum wage and you took
out a hundred and eighty one thousand
dollars in debt
to go to an ivy league you get a
master's degree and you're making a
minimum wage
um anyway continuing the columbia
program offers the most extreme example
of how elite unit universities in recent
years have awarded thousands of masters
degrees that don't provide graduates
enough early
career earnings to begin paying down
their federal student loans
recent columbia film alumni had the
highest debt compared with earnings
among graduates of any major
university master's program in the u.s
the journal found the new york city
university is among the world's most
prestigious schools
and its 11.3 billion endowment ranks in
the nation's
eighth uh ranks it the nation's eighth
wealthiest
private school okay pausing for a moment
um a master's degree in
film for what purpose
you you're gonna get out of grad school
at the age of 36
or whatever 35 a broke
paralyzed by debt and then yada yada
you're a famous film director is that
the plan
you can't yada yada through that what's
what exactly fill in the blanks there
the problem is that nobody is going to
see a film
simply because the director has a
master's degree
here's a conversation that has never
occurred on planet earth one time okay
again this has never
i'll be the first person to say this hey
man let me tell you about this movie i
saw it's really worth watching it's
great
uh you should see it first of all the
director has a master's degree in film
studies
nobody cares about that nobody cares
about most master's degrees
there are a few useful ones but for the
most part grad school is essentially a
glorified ponzi scheme
so back to the article says at new york
university graduates with a master's
degree in publishing
borrowed a median 116 000 and had an
annual median income
of forty two thousand dollars two years
after the program
the data on recent borrowers show at
northwestern university half of those
who earned degrees in speech language
pathology
borrowed 148 thousand dollars or more
and the graduates had a median income of
sixty thousand dollars two years later
graduates of the university of southern
california's marriage and family
counseling program
borrowed a median 124 000
and half earned 50 000 or less over the
same period
then the article starts getting into the
specific sob stories of some of these
pathetic rubes who
mortgage their financial future just so
they could brag about having a master's
degree
i'm not going to subject subject you to
very much of this portion but here's a
taste
um quote there's always those 2 a.m
panic attacks where you're thinking
how the hell am i ever going to pay this
off said 29 year old zach morrison of
new jersey who earned a master's of fine
art in film from columbia in 2018
and praised the quality of the program
his graduate school loan balance now
stands at nearly three hundred thousand
dollars including accrued interest
he has been earning between thirty
thousand and fifty thousand dollars a
year from work
as a hollywood assistant and such side
gigs as commercial video production and
photography
matt black graduated from columbia in
2015 with an mfa
in film and uh 233 thousand dollars in
federal loans
he signed up for an income-based
repayment plan that leaner that in
leaner years requires no remittance from
him
with interest his balance stands at 331
thousand dollars
mr black a 36 year old writer and
producer in los angeles said he grew up
in a lower middle class family in
oklahoma
he earned 60 000 in a good year and less
than half of that in dry stretches
the faculty at columbia was stellar he
said
but he blamed the school for his
calamitous financial situation
he said quote we were told by the
establishment our whole lives
this was the way to jump social classes
instead he feels such goals as marriage
children
and owning a home are now out of reach
okay certainly colombia is partly to
blame for his calamitous financial
situation they're the ones offering this
utterly
worthless product a masters of fine arts
in film worthless
no value and and they offer it and they
make enormous profits off of it
if they were in any other industry
running a scheme like this they'd be
sent to prison
what these colleges are doing is
criminal
they are selling things for enormous
amounts of money
knowing that they are plunging their
students into a lifetime of debt
and they also know that what they're
selling has no value
any other industry you go to jail for
that
but not for universities
so yeah i i blame them all day long but
do you know who else is to blame for
matt black's
calamitous financial situation matt
black
i mean he said it himself as an adult a
grown adult
he took out 233 000
in loans simply because he'd been told
that it's a good way to quote jump
social classes
he did it because he wanted to feel
smarter and better than you and now he's
broker than you and i bet he feels
dumber too
this is vanity materialism
greed not just on the part of the
university but on the part of these
adults
who are buying what they can't afford
hoping it'll be a shortcut to
elite status the whole thing is a mess
from the undergrad level to the grad
student working towards his phd and
finger painting
it is all to borrow a term calamitous
and it's only going to get worse you see
there is no real remedy
as long as we keep pretending that the
best path for everyone
is to spend the first 35 years of their
lives sitting in classrooms
and accumulating pieces of paper and
letters that they can put next to their
names
the answer is is everyone's talking
about well how do we make it cheaper how
do we make it
more affordable how do we make it so
more people could no no no no
that's not the answer the answer isn't
to make sure
more people can do this really stupid
calamitous thing
the answer is to abandon this path or at
least to let people know that there are
many other paths
aside from this one you may have been
told that you need to whittle away the
first third of your life in classrooms
but the people who told you that were
lying
were literally selling you something
you don't need to and most likely you
shouldn't
there are some exceptions but for most
people you should figure out what you
want to do with your life
and then go and simply do it you want to
be in the film industry
then just go and try to do it
there's a really good chance you'll fail
but there's also a really good chance
you'll fail with a master's degree you
still have more debt at the end of that
failure
failure is part of life you want to do
anything worth doing there's a there's a
really good chance of failure
so just go and do it you might need some
college depending what you want to do
or some kind of formal education outside
of high school in order to fully achieve
your goals whatever they are but
there's a very good chance you don't
there's a good chance you don't need any
of that
and it's almost certain that you don't
need any kind of grad school
that's the truth and if we really want
to solve this problem
we need to start telling it now let's
get to our five headlines
now i want to tell you about one of our
newer sponsors on the show carnivore
trading and
i was happy when carnivore trading
reached out because i'm kind of a
perfect customer for them
i'm interested in getting involved in
the market and stocks and investment i
just i don't know very much about it at
all
and that's why carnivore trading is
great listen wall street has been lying
for years
saying a measly few percent is a good
return on our stocks it's not
and also that trading is so complex you
need a financial advisor to do it you
don't all you need is card of our
trading card of our trading is an
anonymous team of elite strategists
they're legends among wall street heavy
hitters and they've gone a bit rogue for
the first time
they're inviting everyday folks like us
like me to uh
to see and mirror their explosive trades
and that's that's how you learn you
learn from the people that are that not
only know about it but are
are doing it and you can see that they
that they know how to do it and that's
the key here
if it sounds too good to be true it's
not carnivore will let you see the
trades they're making right now for two
weeks
free so go to getourtrades.com and use
promo code walsh for two free weeks and
if you join you'll get carnivore's
industry leading promise
that you'll generate three times your
fees after your annual paid subscription
or you'll get a 100
refund you're not going to get that kind
of guarantee anywhere else or this
service anywhere else so go to
get our trades.com promo code walsh get
our trades.com promo code walsh
c website for guaranteed terms and
conditions past performance not a
guarantee
of future earnings all right well um not
a headline but yeah i just i think it's
we should acknowledge it was a
reporter's birthday yesterday
in the white house press pool um some
reporters birthday
and jen pasaki made sure to acknowledge
it now you
i'll play this for you and just ask
yourself
is this the kind of relationship that
you want
the media to have with those in power
[Music]
if democracy dies in darkness as the
washington post says
well then what's happening here exactly
let's uh
let's watch hi everyone hello
happy thursday is it thursday
i said happy thursday well i was gonna
say i did hear it with steve holland's
29th birthday
so happy's 29th birthday i am a terrible
singer but i am willing to lead a song
here if you are
all game
who's with me someone here has a good
voice happy birthday to
you happy birthday to
you happy birthday
dear sea happy birthday
to you
[Music]
all right i will also note brian karam
excellent voice
i don't know what you do with that but
that's that's one thing i learned today
one bit isn't that sweet one big happy
family
isn't that nice and cute to see that
media and government getting along so
well not disturbing at all
how do you go from that to
she's giving it the press briefing
how do you go from that to holding your
feet to the fire and trying to get to
the truth
well you don't there's no way to
transition that but they have no plans
in doing that in the first place
also the other thing that comes to mind
when i listen to that is first of all
she really does have a terrible
she makes me sound like pavarotti with
my singing voice
but also the happy birthday song is just
a terrible song it really is we need a
we need a different can we
as a as a people come together and come
up with a better song it's a bad song
then again i'm anti-birthdays i will say
speaking of birthdays um
and usually i'm a curmudgeon about
birthdays and i don't like the birthday
song or anything
but i was recently uh just a couple
weeks ago i i
there are times when i think celebrating
a birthday is okay
and there are few occasions when even i
can appreciate the birthday song so we
were at i was at a restaurant with my
wife
like two weeks ago and this guy starts
uh
you know starts clanging on his his
glass
to get everyone's attention and then he
lets us know that his
his mom was sitting right next to him is
was celebrating her 100th birthday that
day and then she he led the
entire restaurant in uh
in singing happy birthday for his mom
and i i thought i
even sang can you believe it i didn't
really sing but i i i lip-synced
which is more than i'll usually do
because i thought you know what 100
years
yeah you earned yourself that and then
we looked over in the uh the booth
couple
down from there we noticed there was a
an old couple
had to be in their 80s and they were
sitting there and they were they were
holding hands and
looking deeply into each other's eyes in
their 80s
my wife's looking at that we've got the
100 year birthday
[Music]
and my wife is saying how cute
everything is now and then and then i
and i
appreciate it and i said to her these
were my exact words i said uh
there's a lot of wholesome [ __ ]
happening here tonight which just to
prove that i have a romantic side too
i can appreciate these moments all right
um
i can appreciate this moment too from
the daily wire
reports quote a new york judge sentenced
disgraced lawyer michael avenatti to 30
months in prison
for attempting to extort nike of up to
25 million dollars
the case is one of several avenatti is
currently involved in
while he was addressing the court prior
to the judge's sentence avenatti
reportedly cried
um judge paul gardevi of the southern
district of new york ripped the lawyer
during his sentencing
saying that his conduct was outrageous
he uh
so on and so forth and now he's looking
at 30 months in prison
personally
he committed a crime he's going to jail
he deserves it that's fine
um the fact that he tried to extort nike
i don't really care about that
nike is probably the least sympathetic
company
on earth and the great thing is whether
you're on the right or the left you've
got plenty of reasons to hate nike
so i don't really care that he did that
what i do care about though are
he's actually got he's he's facing
criminal charges
he's got two or three other cases where
he's facing criminal charges
and the more serious things he still has
not gone to trial for including i think
in california
he's accused of defrauding many of his
clients
and these are just normal people this
isn't nike
and he's accused of stealing money from
he could read the details of that
um if you want to know what what a
scumbag this guy is
trying to extort nike that just makes
you really really makes you dishonest
but also incredibly stupid you're not
gonna get away with that
defrauding his clients the way that he
has that makes you stupid also
but an incredible scumbag and now he's
going to prison
and so it's i think a good time to go
back
a little trip down memory lane and see
how the media
treated this guy not all that long ago
we're not going back 15 years
a couple of years ago this
is a put together i believe by the
washington examiner
a nice little montage of the media and
their treatment
of of michael avenatti who now is going
to prison
for extortion and is going to be getting
more prison time for fraud and
everything else
but here's what the media was saying
about him just a couple of years ago
he's donald trump's
worst nightmare michael joining us once
again is michael avenatti let's bring in
michael avenatti michael avenatti
michael avenatti michael avenatti thank
you very much
he's out there saving the country says
he may be the savior of the republic
you are something of a folk hero now i
owe michael avenatti
an apology i've been saying enough
already michael i've seen you everywhere
what do you have left to say
i was wrong brother you have a lot to
say i
i am just dying to hear what you think
because people all like you
i'm the only person right here donald
trump fears more than robert miller we
think
you guys are the tip of the spear that's
going to take down donald trump
michael avenatti's a beast okay that's
true and he's a beast he's obesity
i hand it to her and i hand it to
michael avenatti and he has a great
bigger calling here that being a lawyer
is minimal compared to what he's doing
no one has talked
tougher directly to donald trump on tv
than michael avenatti and donald trump
is afraid to mention his
name okay so you get the idea it goes on
for like another minute that was the
washington free beacon by the way put
that together
uh i mean if they were capable of shame
they would feel it but they
they aren't so it almost feels pointless
to even bring this up
they don't care and it's not like
it it's not like anyone was blindsided
by this
no intelligent person is shocked when
you find out that michael avenatti has
committed extortion as accused of fraud
no no no one is going michael avenatti
did that i can't believe it
of course it was clear from day one the
first time i laid eyes on the guy
and heard him speak he's like okay this
guy's a scumbag
this guy's a rat that's that's very
clear
then we have the worst one i do i do
want to play this the worst one
um of all from the view
and uh this gets
so what you just heard there is hero
worship of michael avenatti
and now we get into full-on deification
listen to this lately to me you're like
the holy spirit
you are all places at all times
right i mean you i do i see you all over
cable news i see you
you know there is a seat available if
you want to be a co-host at the view you
might you know there's people here you
can pitch
there's anna navarro like the holy
spirit that is uh that is
blasphemy of the holy spirit that is
literally the unforgivable sin that she
committed
but again doesn't care no shame no
embarrassment
um and uh michael avenatti going to
prison
okay number two also from the daily wire
says senator rand paul
is planning to introduce legislation to
revoke a federal mask mandate for
travelers on airplanes
the tsa has continued to mandate that
all travelers wear masks on airplanes
with limited exceptions as many state
governments have rolled back
cove 19 restrictions the current tsa
mandate is in place until at least
september 13th
and paul tweeted on thursday when the
senate returns to session i'll be
introducing an immediate repeal of the
mass mandate on planes enough time to
stop this farce
and let people travel in peace
there is there's no reason
there's never been a good reason for it
in my opinion especially now
that's the absurdity of this but living
here in nashville and i've done a lot of
flying recently
in particular and you walk around all
day no one's wearing a mask anywhere
but then you go into an airport and
magically we're all now we all need to
wear a mask there's
no reason to do it whatsoever
it it's they may as well it to anyone
who says yeah well there might be no
reason but it's it's it's not a big deal
it's not
it's not it doesn't cause any real
problems well first of all it does
we i talked a few weeks ago
about the incredible skyrocketing rise
in violent incidents on airplanes
i don't remember the exact number but
usually it's something like there's a
hundred or something
a year across the entire country
where there's some sort of unruly
incident among passengers people get
kicked off
we're at like over a thousand incidents
and we're not even
close to through the year yet and almost
all of that is being driven by the mask
thing
so it is causing problems it's making
people unsafe
when you have these incidents happening
but also
imagine if uh they may as well decree
that when you're in an airport you have
to hop on one leg
that's what you have to do when you're
in the airport hop on one leg
just because and if you don't you get
kicked out
would you go along with that and say
well
all you're doing is hopping on one leg
it's not a big deal
it's utterly arbitrary that's why it's a
big deal there's no reason for us to be
doing this yet we're told to do it
and there are significant consequences
if we don't
uh so at least rand paul's on top of
that and i'll be i'll be interested
to hear what the arguments are from all
the people especially the democrats who
will oppose this move
because you know they're going to
next from the hill it says job openings
held at a record high of 9.2 million
in may while resignations dropped
slightly from historic peak
the number of open jobs on the final
business day of may changed little from
the peak set in april
um quits fell to 3.6 million from a
record high of 3.9 million in april but
remained well above level seen earlier
in the year
and so this is the same story that we've
that we've seen and it's it continues
record numbers of open jobs we've got
companies that are
begging people to come work for them i'm
sure you've seen the same thing i see
these signs all the time now even in
fast food places
begging for employees offering
signing bonuses i don't remember ever
seeing that at a mcdonald's before
but now i see it all the time and with
all the traveling i've been doing i've
been in way too many mcdonald's i have
to say
and many of them have that offering a
signing bonus
i guess the nfl or something to
mcdonald's employees but they can't find
employees
because the government has made it
profitable to just stay home
and you can't you can't have a
functioning society that way
where doing nothing is an option
doing nothing at all when you make that
an option for people you just cannot
function as there is there's no
society that has worked that way
we could have millions of people
choosing to do nothing
it's not like they're dropping out of
the business world because they're
working on the farm
you go back 200 years ago most people
didn't have quote-unquote jobs but they
were
they were still working every day to
live
now try having a society where people
aren't
in a job but they also they aren't doing
any other kind of work and they're just
sitting at home
next uh speaking of businesses here's a
tweet from matt jones
who is according to his bio an
award-winning entrepreneur
and this is not an award-winning idea in
my mind
he says he tweeted now everyone's coming
back to the office we've upgraded our
lanyards so we all know where we're
comfortable
and then you see there are three
lanyards that i guess the employees i
don't know what kind of company this is
but the employees at this company
they can choose between three different
landers there's a green
uh an orange and a red and the green
signifies
that you're okay with hugs and high
fives
orange signifies okay with talking but
not touching
and uh the red says hi i'm keeping my
distance
and all the employees are supposed to
wear one of those to signal to each
other
where their comfort level is in this
post-covered world
is there a lanyard for adults who don't
need to communicate through lanyards
because that's one i would choose also
another question what about colorblind
people
some people can't tell the difference
between red and green if you're
colorblind
so they're going to be charging in there
trying to bear hug the red lanyard
people
which actually is pretty great come to
think of it
although i mean who is hugging at work
anyway
sounds like a it's a literal invitation
for sexual harassment complaints
hug okay with hugs at work
maybe there should be another lanyard a
dark green which says um
i want to hold my co-workers in an
erotic embrace
and whisper my sensual fantasies into
their ears i mean if we're hugging we
might as well go all the way around the
bases i guess
um you know the thing is i if i had to
choose one of these really
if i had to choose one i would go with
red i would go with the
stay the hell away from me you freak's
lanyard
but not because of covid just because
i'm an anti-social hermit
and frankly as an anti-social hermit i'm
this is one of the things that has
really bothered me over the last year
is to see my culture and my way of life
being appropriated by the coveted people
and so when i when i just operate the
way that i always have
keeping my distance from people now it's
assumed that i'm worried about
well no that's not it at all i had this
experience on an elevator a couple weeks
ago
i was on the elevator and um then
someone comes running down the hall this
guy and he's like oh hold that hold that
and of course i'm not holding the
elevator for you i just stood there and
it closed
you can catch the next one it'll take 20
seconds for the next one to come
and and then i felt bad not because i
didn't hold the elevator for him but
because i realized he probably thought
i was afraid of covid and that's why i
didn't want him on the elevator
no it's not that at all i just don't
like human interaction
that's it not covid related
all right finally uh so i've been
meaning to talk about this for a few
days
rachel nichols over at espn
um she's a espn personality
and she was accidentally i'm still not
sure exactly how this is supposed to
have happened but she was having a
private conversation with someone
and she was accidentally quote unquote
recorded on on someone's cell phone in
this private conversation complaining
that espn had given her nba hosting gig
to a black
female personality at the channel and
and she was saying that she'd been given
that job for diversity reasons
and this this recording was circulated
around espn and it was like this
happened a year ago and it was
people knew about it at espn it kind of
made the rounds it never went public
um and uh and now suddenly it is public
and first of all here is the this is
from the new york times they released it
here is rachel nichols talking about
this issue here it is so they said to me
hey instead of hosting the nba finals
like why don't you do doris's cylon
reporter job for the nba finals
because guess what that will clear the
way for
[Music]
uh for
maria to do the hosting for them yeah
so i have declined i don't know what
their next move is
but they are feeling pressure because of
all of that and
i'm trying to figure out like how to
just you know my thing is like i
am i wish mary taylor all the success in
the world she covers football she
covered basketball
would you need her to give her more
things to do because you're feeling
pressure about your like crappy long
time
record on diversity which by the way i
myself like know personally from the
female side of it like go for it just
you know find it somewhere else like
you're not going to find it with me and
taking my thing away
so that's rachel nichols she's the the
white woman
and she was replaced by that was a
conversation from last july
and uh maria taylor is the woman that
she was replaced by for hosting the nba
finals
um and as it happens another big
coincidence here
that maria taylor who got the the
hosting gig
and remember this so this this audio has
been circulating around the company
internally everyone knew about it um
maria taylor's
contract was she was up for a contract
extension she was negotiating contract
and that's gonna be happening the next
week or two and so right when
this contract negotiation is happening
that's when this uh
audio goes public what a big coincidence
and now uh rachel nichols had so she had
been taken off of the hosting gig
and it had been given to maria taylor
that's what she was complaining about
now that this has gone public she was
removed also as a sideline reporter
which is what she had been demoted to
and she was replaced by a woman by the
name of malika andrews
who is also a black woman so she was
she was complaining you know that she
had been
replaced by a black woman for diversity
purposes and because of that complaint
rather because the complaint went public
espn punished her by replacing her again
maria taylor though by the way she
finally spoke out about this issue she
had been kind of quiet about it
and uh she finally tweeted yesterday she
said during the dark times i always
remember that i am in this position to
open doors
and light the path that others walk down
i've taken some punches
but that just means i'm still in the
fight remember to lift as you climb and
always
keep rising okay so she's the
you know she's the hero and also the
victim in this situation
clear from her tweet here
it doesn't even make why
i don't watch espn and i also don't
watch the nba
and i don't care who hosts it but
it certainly seems very plausible that
rachel nichols is correct
in her original assessment if she had
had this job and she was good at it if
that's the case
and then she was suddenly taken off of
the job right when
the blm stuff was uh was happening last
summer
replaced by a black woman really good
chance that it was done for political
and quote diversity reasons
but why would espn shy away from that
are they supposed to be open about that
they're trying to give an opportunity to
uh
you know trying to diversify and give an
opportunity to
an underrepresented person
meanwhile rachel nichols is woke
and leftist herself at this point you
couldn't possibly work at espn if you're
not
and you know she supports blm and all
that kind of stuff
and this is what she gets for her
trouble that's the way it always goes
but these people will never learn um
i said that was the final thing but i i
i can't forget about this there is one
thing more important than anything else
we've talked about so far today
um you know we've heard a lot of uh
there's been a lot of effort to get
people
vaccinated all the holdouts joe biden is
going to be going door to door
but a big part of the effort has been
all these songs that we've heard
and uh the rapper juvenile back from the
90s you may remember him if you're a 90s
kid
he did a remix of his uh back that ass
up or rather back that thing up
the radio edit and only now it's vax
that thing up
and i just thought we should play that
for you because it's pretty great here
it is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we gonna be romance saying girl you
could be the queen at the quarantine
we could meet up at the spot and we
could do the thing internet day
i'm your mate download the app shawty
you ain't got a weight chance i love it
when your homie
ain't playing emoji you could be the
i think we basically get the idea use a
handsome young brother
why don't you vax that thing up that's
not creepy at all
i'm just wondering is there anyone who
wasn't convinced
so far about vaccinations
and and but will be convinced by this
who are we even trying to to convince at
this point
with these sorts of things who is the
person
at this point the vaccine's been out for
months
readily available for months everyone
knows that it's there they know where
they can get it they know
they know the whole spiel and yet there
are plenty of people who for one reason
or another said
i i don't i don't want it not interested
thank you
thanks but no thanks so is there anyone
who has held that position for months
now and is now going to say well
after seeing that they're going to say
well you know your raise is a good point
perhaps i should indeed vax that thing
up
i don't know who that person maybe they
call calls his wife up hey honey i know
we said we weren't doing the vaccine but
uh listen i just heard this song
any and he was bringing up the point
that we need to vax that thing up
and i'm starting to think maybe we
really should
somehow i doubt that that conversation
is happening but i could be wrong
let's go down to reading youtube
comments um
dylan says matt do you know what kind of
car ben drives
i've always imagined him in something
classy like a bmw oh and please spare me
i already know that you drive a minivan
aka the dad wagon i don't know what kind
of car ben drives but
um please don't stereotype me i don't
drive a minivan in fact
i have nothing against minivans this is
the struggle that everyone goes through
when they get into like middle age and
they're they're having kids you know
and once you get to like three or four
kids
um you start to realize that you got to
make the minivan move
and but but a lot of people don't want
to do that they have some
prejudice against minivans that i don't
understand my wife is in that category
she absolutely refuses we have four kids
that would cram them into suvs she
refuses to get a minivan
i don't understand why they're practical
they're handsome vehicles what's the
problem
um ashley says pre-k is unnecessary and
kindergarten probably is as well
then if you homeschool you can move
through the grades quicker and get your
ged at a younger age honestly 12 years
is too much
yeah we we're expanding public education
to 14 years 16 years
we got to get the kids in younger and
younger really it should be less and
that's true
and this is something that people when
they start homeschooling
i hear this all the time from homeschool
parents that they're shocked
by by especially if they went to public
school themselves or if they had their
kids in public school and they pulled
them out
they're shocked when they realize just
how much time is wasted
in public school because you have your
curriculum
and especially when your kids are
younger you know they're in first second
grade and that
elementary school aged you can you can
give them a full days of a full day of
education in a couple of hours
you give you can give them the same
amount of education that they will get
if they were in in a public school
building
or more only you could do it in two
hours
or less as opposed to seven
and why is that because there's just so
much time wasted in these classrooms
on subjects that are irrelevant they're
watching movies they're you know they
got to go from classroom classroom in
the hallways they got lunch they got gym
they got this and that
um just a lot a lot of busy work
you cut all that out and you realize
that
that right now there's kids are in
school for longer than they need to be a
lot longer
and yeah pre-k is just daycare
a three or four-year-old kid there's
there's no kind of formal
sit-down education that you're gonna
give to a four-year-old
um at that age
at that age you know how kids learn they
learn through playing
you you learn education is through
through just being kids and playing
games that's how they learn
and no you don't need to be in a in a
classroom setting in order to do that
um t loco says matt gotta say
i lost a ton of respect for you with
your comments on the peacock story
killing a bird because it's doing what
it naturally does is no reason to kill
it
would you want to live next neighbors
like that hope they hang the bastards
who killed it
and paid for the contract really really
tiloco
the person who killed a peacock you want
to hang them you think they should be
killed
but eye for eye here blood for blood a
peacock for a human life that's what you
think
yeah i got a lot of backlash for my
position on the peacock story
there was a peacock that had been tara
if you didn't watch the show you say
there's a peacock that had been
terrorizing this neighborhood
um and peacocks yeah they have pretty
beautiful flat feathers but they also
make a really
loud annoying sound and they don't shut
up and so this peacock had been visiting
this neighborhood for six years
tormenting people at all hours of the
day and finally someone put an ad out on
craigslist and said hey
you know i'm looking for someone who
could just kill this peacock hired a
peacock assassin and next thing you know
the peacock was taken care of
and i fully support that i i
support your right to kill annoying
peacocks i do
and listen t loco you like i said
yesterday
i know damn well and so do you that if
this was a vulture
or a crow you know if there was some
crow that had been going through
people's garbage
or even a wild turkey some
ugly animal that doesn't have the pretty
feathers you wouldn't care that anyone
shot it
you would say oh that's a pest we have
some animals that
are pests and some animals that are not
and if you kill the pests it's okay but
if you kill the animals that aren't
pests it's bad
how do we determine the pests from the
non-pest mostly it's just whichever one
we think is cute
so uh a lot of backlash for that i i am
unwavering though in my my stance on
this
and my support for um for murdering
peacocks
only the annoying ones okay i'm not
saying if someone has a peacock farm i'm
not saying you just you can
go there and just start start firing
away i'm just saying
the ones who are pests i support that
and then um
in fact uh our producers mckenna and
sean put a
so i thought that i was in the minority
but they put a poll up under the
comments there
and i guess what was it was it was it 25
to 21 in favor of killing the peacock
that's what i was told
okay 25 to 21. so i'm not fully in the
minority like i thought it was
and then finally aaron says my siblings
have used peacock calls to get each
other's attention for years
very distinct sound wait
my siblings have used peacock calls to
get each other's attention
your siblings peacocks are they humans
why not just use each other's names
what how do you put that in the comments
like it's a normal thing
with no explanation no context oh yeah
my siblings always use peacock calls
what are they adults so you're at
thanksgiving dinner and you and you're
using peacock calls to each other across
the table
do you have names
what kind of bizarre thing is that
all right well thanks for watching
anyway erin oh one other thing um
i also wanted to mention this this is
pretty exciting
so this was presented to me yesterday
you know that uh that we recently
decided if you're a fan of this show
you are a member of the sweet baby gang
that's the name
whether you like it or not if you're if
you're in the audience you're part of
the sweet baby gang
uh how did we come up with that name
it's it's you have to be there it's an
inside joke i'm not gonna get into it i
don't even remember where this
came from but it's a sweet baby gang
that's what we are and uh there have
been people
in the comments for for weeks now
uh begging for sweet baby gang
merchandise
and this was presented to me yesterday
and we finally have it sort of um
i guess i'll show here's the bicep cam
and i think maybe you could probably see
better
so that's the sweet baby gang shirt it
says sweet baby gang and then
i was shown this shirt and uh i it's a
beautiful shirt and
it's also viscerally deeply disturbing
at the same time
because there is me with a diaper on
crawling on the ground so i i'm
disturbed by it i'm horrified
um but i also like it at the same time
so now this is not for sale though this
is just for me
we haven't actually put these on sale so
this is merchandise just for me if but
if you want sweet baby gang if you want
that shirt
then you have to just you have to let us
know
cry out for it in the comments and uh
maybe i can convince them to actually
put this
i don't know if the company be too
embarrassed to sell this
or it's just too weird i'm not sure but
we'll uh we'll see
you know if you're the do-it-yourselfer
type especially when it comes to cars
then uh then you know you might find
yourself needing auto parts
where do you get them or the what most
people do is they just get in the car
and go to the auto parts store but the
problem
as i'm always telling you is that you go
there you're wasting time you're wasting
money because the stuff's gonna be more
expensive than
it otherwise should be and they're also
probably not gonna have what you need in
stock they're not gonna have the kind of
selection that they do
at rockauto.com which you can access
anytime
um just on your phone on your laptop
it's as easy as that just go to
rockauto.com
they always offer the lowest prices
possible if you find it on rockauto.com
you don't need to keep window shopping
because you know that you found the best
price possible they're also a family
business
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years you can go
to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
the catalog is unique it's very easy for
anyone to navigate and you can quickly
see
everything you could be looking for all
the parts available and you can specify
based on the brand the specifications
the prices you prefer you can narrow it
down that way so it's very easy to do
so go to rockauto.com right now see all
the parts available for your car
truck right walsh in there how did you
hear about this box so they know that
we sent you here's something else you
could do after you go to rockauto.com
uh pick up michael knowles's new book
which you may have heard him mention a
time or two it's now out
speechless controlling words controlling
minds and this is all about
you know we hear about political
correctness um
most people say that they're against it
but with uh with speechless controlling
words controlling minds if you haven't
picked up a copy
now is the time to do it the book takes
you through the origins of political
correctness and why it's absolutely
essential that we
stand up and fight it's insidious spread
into every public
institution in america because if we
don't the consequences are
waiting for us and our children in the
not too distant future
if you don't know where to start don't
worry because in the book
michael knowles gives you the tools you
need to understand and spot political
correctness in order to stop it
uh it's a great book a lot of great
insight and uh so
pick up a copy now speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available everywhere right now if you
don't want to make a trip to the
bookstore you can always pick it up on
amazon and hard
cover and kindle edition right now now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we cancel scarlett johansson she's
doing the media rounds to promote her
new superhero movie which
is i believe the 94th film in the marvel
extended universe
interestingly enough even though it has
produced so many movies
it turns out that this universe is quite
small because all of the movies are
exactly the same they all have the same
basic plot
and action sequences and message not to
spoil anything but the message for all
of these movies
to summarize is bad guy is bad
punch bad guy kick bad guy good guy win
the end now buy the merchandise
that's basically the message um and the
point of all these movies now i may be
selling marvel a little short here
because sometimes the movies do have a
deeper message which brings us to
scarlett johansson
and her interview with glamour magazine
she was asked about the deeper themes
and messages of her new film black widow
which is a movie about an attractive
woman in a leather jumpsuit kicking
people
at least that's what that's what it's
about on the surface but what is the
film really saying
what is it truly trying to convey about
the nature of kicking
and jumpsuits and hot blonde chicks
here's johansen trying to explain well i
do
think the film is inherently female
be partly because of kate shortland
directing it it definitely
has um you know it sheds
light on
it sheds light on a
you know um on an imbalance i think
that uh women feel like inherently
because of how our society is
has been forever thousands and thousands
of years
and um you know the movie is
about the subjugation of women and
um you know the trauma that uh
we have to help one another out of
oh okay now to be fair to scarlett here
the actual question she was asked
verbatim this was a question
how important is it to push the
conversation around gendered superheroes
that question doesn't mean anything she
was apparently being interviewed by a
random progressive buzzword
generator so she did her best to to take
the discussion to some place that was
moderately intelligible
but she was hobbled again by the fact
that the movie she's promoting is
incredibly bad and stupid
and exists almost entirely as a vehicle
to sell toys and promote the brand
that's all marvel movies marvel movies
are made by algorithms not people
i would respect her if she just said
that but she can't so instead she
reaches for some kind of socially
conscious
message and she kept reaching in
response to the next question
which was again verbatim what have you
been your own
when have you been your own ally the
most
that was the question when have you been
your own ally
the most so once again the question
makes no sense
but here's what she said oh my gosh yeah
i think you have to be
all that's as a woman you have to be all
the time
um you know because we are
under minded and underserved and under
appreciated and underpaid and you have
to be your own ally
um you know my mom instilled that in me
for when i was
really really young because of course
she'd experienced it even
more severely than i than i did and
you know equal pay is a huge part of of
that
fight um when i even when i was a
teenager in the industry
or a young woman i should say my mom you
know would
have those conversations like what why
is she not getting you know that it had
never had anything to do
there was always these these like
these little key terms like um you know
bank ability and you know box office
draw and those are all
uh way those are all terms that are
basically masquerading
as sexism
okay um
undermined underserved under appreciated
underpaid
this poor woman i might have to start
another gofundme i'm thinking
she can barely make ends meet she's on
the verge of starvation nobody
appreciates her
or surfs or pays her this is a real
problem i saw
scarlett johansson out on a street
corner just the other day huddled under
a blanket with a jar full of coins
uh you know it it well i think it was
scarlett johansson it might have been
might have been just a drunk guy i don't
know but consider this and get ready to
burst into tears when you hear this
scarlett johansson only makes
about 50 million dollars a year at least
that's what she earned in 2019 only 50
million dollars
this is a real life handmaid's tale this
is the patriarchy plain as day
we are living in a country where a woman
can only make
50 million dollars in a calendar year
now you might say that 50 million
dollars is quite a lot of money you
might say that scarlett johansson
rich beautiful famous beloved not
beloved by me especially but by other
people
um you might say that she should simply
be happy and grateful because life has
granted her all of the material
blessings
a person can ever hope to be given
but the problem for johansson is that
although she has so much
still other people have more yes she
makes a ton of money off of her
marvel films but male action heroes male
action stars
make two tons of money they make even
more
and it must be because of sexism she
says yes it must or
maybe women in hollywood generally get
paid less
still a lot but less because the movies
that make all the money
are action movies especially superhero
movies and those kinds of movies
are more successful that is more people
watch them they sell more tickets they
get more downloads on streaming
when they star men in other words male
stars get paid more because they're
worth more in terms of pure dollars and
cents
the daily wire article reporting on this
story gives the example of the two most
recent films
starring new superheroes in the marvel
cinematic universe black panther and
captain marvel
the former earned 700 million
domestically while the latter earned 427
million
the former was led by a man the latter
by a woman and these are that's
generally how these things go
why well i think it's because audiences
in general mostly prefer to see
men in these kinds of roles
most members of the audience would never
say that because they can't say that
but the box office speaks for itself
um generally that's what the audience
wants
the studios and hollywood that's not
what they want that's not what they
want us to want as an audience but it is
what the audience wants
part of that is because the studios why
are the the female action
movies and superhero movies less popular
part of that is because the studios
can't help but inject a bunch of cringy
girl power stuff
into the female action movies and so
audiences are turned off by that while
the
the male action movies will just be
action movies
but also part of it is that men most of
the time
from the audience's perspective make
more compelling and convincing action
heroes
perhaps it's mentally exhausting for the
audience to watch a 112 pound blonde
woman
in this kind of role because you have to
strain a bit to take the movie seriously
when she's beating up like 14 armed
thugs at once
you don't have to strain quite as much
watching like the rock do the same
even though it's fiction in both cases
i'm just speculating here
whatever the reason the fact is that
these sorts of movies when there is a
man in the starring role tend to perform
better
audiences tend to be more interested so
those stars get paid a little more
it's not sexism it's economics
and that's why i must say to scarlett
johansson not because she's a woman
but just because she's a whiny entitled
narcissist
you are canceled scarlett johansson is
cancelled
grad students are canceled but you know
who is not canceled
the sweet baby gang thanks for watching
as always thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. hey
everybody this is andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic
with me andrew clavin